كم عدد الأيام التي كنت فيها
مريضًا لخمسة أيام تبدو رائعًا
، يجب أن أقول إنك تبدو رائعًا وأنت
تعلم أنك كنت ترسم مسار
مرضك على Twitter للناس ، لذا
يمكنك أن تأخذنا من خلاله  اليوم الأول ،
ما هي أعراضك ، اليوم الثاني ، ما
هي أعراضك ، اليوم الثالث ، وما إلى ذلك ،
تأكد من أنه في اليوم الأول بدأت مع
بعض القشعريرة مع التهاب الحلق والسعال
والصداع الرهيب والحمى منخفضة الدرجة
ثم الانتقال إلى اليوم إلى
الثقيلة  بدأت في التلاشي ، بدأت
بإسهال خفيف خفيف
وتختفي الحمى المنخفضة الدرجة أيضًا السعال الذي
ما زلت أتقنه في اليوم الثالث ، بدأت
أشعر بتحسن قليل أثناء
تحدثك ، وضعنا الموجات فوق الصوتية
لديك أصوات قائظ للغاية كل  يوم من
رئتيك وماذا لو تمكنا من وضع
هؤلاء مرة أخرى
ما يصعب علينا معرفة ما
نراه بالطبع ولكن ما تراه
يحدث في رئتيك خلال اليوم
لما أراه من الموجات فوق الصوتية هو التعتيم
الذي هو  يرتبط بالتهاب رئوي  لذا
فإن الترجمة إلى الموجات فوق الصوتية الخاصة بي ستكون
التهابًا رئويًا ، لذا فقد أصبت
بالتهاب رئوي بسبب هذا ،
نعم ، الالتهاب الرئوي شائع يعني أن هذا هو
SIA - الآن أنا بخير
وهذا طبيب رائع ونحن سعداء
جدًا لسماع ذلك  أنت كما نقول طبيبًا
في المستشفى الجامعي في مدريد بإسبانيا ،
فالأطباء بالطبع حذرون للغاية ،
أعني أنكم جميعًا ترتدون قفازات ، تغسلون
يديك طوال الوقت الذي ترتدون فيه ملابس واقية
وهكذا هل تعرفون بالضبط كيف
أصابتها بفيروس أو  هل هو مجرد
مجتمع منتشر في المستشفى الخاص بك ، كان أحد
زملائي إيجابيًا على
الأرجح قبل البقية منا ، لذا فهذه
رسالة أريد أن أرسلها إلى
زملائي الطبيب الزملاء
لتوخي الحذر في أي شخص تظهر عليه الأعراض
لتجنب أي اتصال أو حتى  عمل
مثير للاهتمام ، بمعنى آخر ، قبل أن
تبدأ جميعًا في ارتداء جميع
الملابس الواقية ، كان أحد
زملائك إيجابيًا وربما
نشرها من خلال اللمس من خلال
المؤتمر من خلال سورفا  ce نعم في
ذلك الوقت ، لم يكن أحد يعلم أن الأمر كان إيجابيًا ، ولكن
بعد اختباراتي الإيجابية ، استمر
أيضًا وأخبر أنه كان
أول من يعاني من الأعراض ، نعتقد أنه يمكن أن
يكون طبيب الصلصة متى ستتمكن
من العودة إلى العمل  ربما في غضون أسبوع واحد ،
وآمل إذا سارت الأمور على ما يرام
، فقد حصلت قريبًا لأنني لا أعاني من الأعراض ،
يمكنني إعادة اختباري وإذا تحولت إلى
سلبية ، يمكنني العودة إلى العمل ،
وربما يسحبني رؤسائي
في المقدمة  خط لرؤية جميع المرضى
بصحة جيدة ، الطبيب لي تشون تشيانغ ، الجميع
يقدر أن تكون قادرًا على مشاهدة
ما مررت به ثم مشاهدة تعافيك السريع ،
شكرًا جزيلاً على مشاركة
قصتك الشخصية معنا اليوم
طوال الأسبوع ، لقد تلقينا جميع
أنواع الأسئلة  حول فيروس كورونا
، استمروا في
طرح أسئلة مختلفة من الأسبوع الماضي ومختلفة
عن الأسبوع السابق لذلك أردنا أن
نحاول الإجابة على أكبر عدد ممكن منهم ،
لذا فإن السؤال الأول عندما يتعلق الأمر
باتخاذ الاحتياطات اللازمة  o vid 19
أو الفيروس التاجي الجديد في المكتب ،
ما الذي يمكن للموظفين فعله ، أعتقد أن الأساسيات
تنطبق بالتأكيد إذا كنت
مريضًا لا تأتي إلى العمل ، أعني أن هذا
صحيح مع أو بدون انتشار عدوى فيروس كورونا
إذا رأيت شخصًا
مريضًا بشكل واضح  لن أكون بالقرب من هذا
الشخص وعندما أقول لا تكون قريبًا من ذلك الشخص ،
فإن المسافة التي
ستكون عليها قطيرات الجهاز التنفسي هي
أنها تقول حوالي 6 أقدام و 3 إلى 6 أقدام ،
لذا فهذه مسافة آمنة من
حيث المسافة الاجتماعية  داخل مساحة مكتبية
داخل أي نوع من المساحات حقًا
، وبالمناسبة ، يتم إلغاء الكثير من هذه
التجمعات الكبيرة بشكل متزايد
لأنه من الصعب
العثور على المسافة الاجتماعية للأشخاص الذين
يجلسون بجوار بعضهم البعض
مباشرة  لبعضكم البعض ، لذا
حافظوا على المسافة والبقاء في المنزل إذا كنتم
مريضًا ، فإن
الأسطح النظيفة قدر الإمكان
تعلمون أن هذا الشخص المجنون
بالمناديل المبللة لفترة طويلة كنت ذلك
الشخص المجنون لفترة طويلة على
ما أعتقد  أعتقد أنه يمكنك حقًا أن تكون
مفيدًا ما هي بعض الطرق الشائعة التي
ينشر بها الناس الجراثيم والفيروسات في
المكاتب ، نفس الشيء الذي ينشرونه
عادةً من خلال قطرات الجهاز التنفسي
، ثم عن طريق لمس
الأشياء التي تحرك يدك ولمس
شيئًا آخر يحرك الفيروس  من
مكان إلى مكان آخر ثم
يلمسه شخص ما ويصاب بالعدوى ،
فحاول ألا تلمس الأشياء التي أعتقد
أنها صعبة ، وعندما أقول لمس
الأشياء ، أعني أن تلمس الأشياء تلمس
الأسطح التي تلامس وجهك ، وحاول ألا
تفعل ذلك  قدر الإمكان ، ما
الذي ستفعله ، ما الذي توصي به للحفاظ على
صحتنا العقلية والتحقق من ذلك بينما
نزيد التباعد الاجتماعي والعمل
عن بُعد ، إنه سؤال رائع وأنا
أفكر كثيرًا شخصيًا مع
عائلتي أصدقائي
أولاً وقبل كل شيء  لا
يجب أن يعني التباعد الاجتماعي العزلة الاجتماعية ، حسنًا ، أعتقد أن
هناك العديد من الطرق التي لا يزال بإمكاننا القول أنها
يمكن أن تبقى على اتصال
، وربما يمكننا حتى أن نقول أكثر ارتباطًا
مما نكتبه  فعل شيئًا واحدًا حيال
هذا الفيروس هو أنني كنت أبلغ عنه
لفترة طويلة الآن وتحدثت إلى الكثير من
الناس هنا في الولايات المتحدة وفي
أماكن أخرى حول العالم هو أن
هناك هذا الإدراك وأعتقد
أننا  كل هذا معًا ، نحن
هذا هو العامل الممرض الذي تعرف أنه
يؤثر على الجميع ولا
يميز ضد أي شخص نحن جميعًا في
هذا معًا ونحن في وضع
الآن حيث يكون لسلوكياتنا الفردية
مثل هذا التأثير على الأشخاص من حولنا
تعتمد
صحتك بشكل كبير على الطريقة التي أتصرف بها وتعتمد صحتي بشكل كبير على
كيفية تصرفك ، لذلك إذا كنت تمارس
النظافة الجيدة وتتأكد من أنك لست
مصدرًا للانتشار ، فأنت تفعل ذلك ليس
فقط لنفسك  القيام بذلك من أجل
جميع الأشخاص من حولك أيضًا
وأعتقد أن هناك شيئًا
ما بطريقة تجمعنا معًا بطريقة
لم أرها من قبل وأعتقد
أن ذلك ربما يخفف
قليلاً من القلق ويجمعنا
معًا